hey y'all flickers of fear time
so we're talking about an old movie an
old british movie
on this installment going back to my
birth year of 1972
we're going to be talking about a movie
called asylum
also known as house of crazies although
i don't like that title as much
so if you know anything about british
horror
probably the most famous uh studio
particularly the 60s and 70s was hammer
obviously they did a lot of you know
gothic horror dracula frankenstein all
that kind of stuff
however there was also i don't know if
i'd necessarily call them rivals
i guess they sort of were but they you
know kind of had a different
market i suppose but the other studio
was amicus
now amicus kind of more made their
you know they they made their money
doing anthology films largely i think
they only did one or two movies that
were not anthologies uh one of which i
believe was and now the screaming starts
which we talked about on the movie
retrospective a little while back
um and actually that movie and this
movie had the same director
roy ward baker uh who also did
[ __ ] man he did some other amicus stuff
he did uh the vault of horror
and uh he did some hammer films too i
believe he did um
uh let's see scars of dracula um he's
the vampire lovers quatermass in the pit
he also did uh moon zero two which was
on mystery science theater if you want
to check that out not a
super memorable movie but the you know
the msd episode was good but yeah so
amicus was kind of known for doing
horror anthology films or as they called
them portmanteau
movies many of which were actually
written by
robert block who actually did a lot of
writing for movies and tv but probably
best known today as being the dude that
wrote the novel
psycho on which the very famous alfred
hitchcock film was based
so that's kind of what you have here
i've seen like a lot of the amicus
anthologies i mean if you have been
following this show at all it's like you
know that i
i just really have a lot of fondness for
horror anthologies i'm not really sure
why um i like hor
i like short stories i like to write
them i like to read them i don't know
there's just something about them that
really appeals to me
so i kind of like the idea of doing a
movie with all these sort of
intertwining stories
so i feel like asylum has like a really
great
framing device now the framing device of
this film
is there's a dude named dr martin
and he arrives at this uh insane asylum
obviously uh to the tune of knight on
bald mountain
because you know it's uh how you
pronounce his name mizorksky or whatever
it's obviously if you see in fantasia
that's you know an iconic piece of music
and it's in the public domain so you
know
it was kind of cheaper for because that
was kind of what amicus did they would
sort of like
you know do these low budget and i don't
mean that as i said to sound like
derogatory uh they did a lot with the
little budget that they had but yeah
like i said they they were kind of
whereas hammer was doing more gothic
type stuff
um i feel like amicus was doing more
contemporary
morality tales kind of like an easy
comics type of
thing that you would see later on with
creep show not quite as lurid as that
but you know tales of revenge or you
know people getting their just desserts
or something like that and a lot of the
stories uh from their anthologies were
kind of like that and asylum
is no exception so yeah so dr martin
shows up at this
uh asylum and he's being interviewed for
a job here now the guy that's
interviewing him for the job is dr
rutherford
who is played by patrick mcgee and it's
really weird because um i always know
him i mean he was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff
he was in uh mask of the red death which
we talked about not too long ago
he was also in a clockwork orange and
the funny thing about that was when he
was in a clockwork orange
you know he played that character that
writer that was um you know he got
attacked and like then later he was in a
wheelchair
he is also in a wheelchair in this movie
and uh
so that he says the reason that he's in
a wheelchair is because
one of the inmates in the asylum you
know he had turned his back on him and
he attacked him so i guess he you know
crippled him for life or whatever now dr
martin
i guess that dr rutherford is not real
jazzed about
dr martin's credentials maybe he thinks
he can't cut it you know with the asylum
or whatever
so he kind of gives him this little
task this little game like to see if
he's got what it takes
basically he's like okay um the inmate
that attacked me
is dr starr who used to be the head
of this asylum but then had a nervous
breakdown and is now a patient
now you're gonna go and interview these
four patients and
i don't know if that's the only four
that are in there but whatever so he's
gonna go interview these four patients
and he's like
if you can tell me which one is dr starr
then you can have the job so that's
essentially what the wrap around story
is
so then he goes and interviews each
person
that person tells kind of their sob
story or how they ended up in the asylum
and then you also have this ongoing
mystery
like a through line of who you know
which one of them is dr
starr uh you know because like i said
when dr martin gets there he doesn't
know what dr char looks like he doesn't
even know if it's a man or a woman
because like i said you know two of the
uh two of the inmates are women or two
are men uh so it could be any one of
them
you know so i don't know if i've seen
like a couple other reviews of this and
it seems like even though this came out
in 1972
it's like nobody really wants to spoil
the big reveal of who dr starr turns out
to be
so i guess i won't either but you can
still enjoy the movie not knowing that i
just like that they had that little
added
you know that little added through line
where it's like you know you were trying
to figure out like
which one was which and you know you
didn't know if like dr martin would be
able to figure out like which one it was
so i kind of like that they had that
little added mystery going on in there
so basically so that's kind of your wrap
around and then they go
into each of the patients stories as he
goes and
interrogates them about their whatever
now as i said
all of these stories were written by
robert block
i believe that most of the stories had
already been published in pulp magazines
prior
and he just adapted them for this
particular movie and i guess this frame
story was actually
based on one of his short stories called
a home away from home
and that was actually uh published in
the alfred hitchcock mystery magazine
and it was also adapted for tv on the
alfred hitchcock hour if you guys
remember that show and they did a lot of
robert block stories as well
and uh this framing story here was one
of the ones that they did
now the first story which actually i
really like i think the imagery and the
first story is probably the creepiest
i will say though the first story is
like the shortest
uh the most predictable and it's almost
it's so short in fact that it almost
kind of seems more like a vignette
really than a story because it's like
you
you know you know where it's gonna go
like pretty much from the jump so
basically
uh the first one's called frozen fear
and
there's this uh the patient that's in
the asylum that's telling this story is
this woman named bonnie
now she has been uh knocking boots with
this married dude
and the married dude is his name is
walter and
he has a wife ruth who's apparently
super rich
and they despise each other but i guess
she doesn't want to divorce him because
he thinks
that he's going to take all her money or
something like that or she enjoys like
torturing him like just by not giving
him a divorce
so he can go be with his mistress or
whatever so there's that whole setup
um she does appear to know that the
husband is [ __ ] around on her
uh also ruth a little bit into voodoo
um which they kind of get into at the
little beginning there which
obviously is going to come into play
later on so pretty much all that happens
in this one
is that walter and bonnie the mistress
they're basically like well you know we
gotta kill this [ __ ] right
because we gotta get her out of the way
and then we'll have all our money it'll
be a win-win so
so instead of doing something kind of
simple or easy you know just like
poisoning or pushing her off a cliff or
whatever
walter decides he's going to kill her
with an axe
and cut her body into pieces wrap each
of the pieces
in like brown butcher paper and then
he's gonna put him in a freezer
and profit i don't know i you know he's
gonna do something with him later i
think he's going to dump them like at
different places
you know to get rid of them however uh
it will come as a surprise to no one
that because
ruth was into voodoo and [ __ ] um the
voodoo magic like pretty much
reanimates all of her separate parts
and they come crawling after the
evildoers
and uh and like i said it's it's
actually pretty effective i really
really like the shot of ruth's
severed head like wrapped in this brown
paper
kind of coming after the mistress or
whatever and like the mouth is going
like in and out like it's breathing and
stuff
and then you know there's like legs
scooting across the floor like all so
it's actually like this is not a gory
movie by any stretch of the imagination
i don't remember it being
particularly bloody or anything but it
does have a lot of like really effective
like creepy imagery like that
so like i said this just a very basic
like straight up revenge story
you know the body parts come they kill
walter bonnie gets away but because
the her story sounds outlandish uh they
put her in the asylum that's how she
ended up there
now the second story is called the weird
tailor and this is a very very strange
story this is actually the one that
peter cushing is in
he's not in this movie very much he's
only in this one segment uh and he's
only in like kind of two scenes
but obviously he's always going to class
up the joint because you know everybody
loves peter cushing come on
so uh so this is about a dude named
bruno who was a tailor
and he's fallen on some hard times him
and his wife
and uh he doesn't have any money and uh
his landlord
is kind of you know pounding down the
door like wanting the rent money and
whatnot
and bruno is like [ __ ] man what are we
gonna do and then it turns out that
peter cushing
shows up with this really really strange
other worldlyish looking fabric it's
kind of like what i don't know it's like
weird like
iridescent i can't really describe it so
he turns up and he's like i want
i'll pay you 200 pounds if you make this
suit
like to these specifications and he has
like this weird book that looks kind of
like a grammar or whatever
but he has everything kind of drawn out
and he's like oh and
you can only work on it between the
hours of like midnight and 3am or
something like that he has like all
these stipulations
and he said and i'm making it for my son
and it's like a surprise for him
so uh yeah but he says astrology is why
he's like oh i believe in astrology and
that's why you can only work on it like
during certain times or whatever
so bruno is just kind of like okay weird
but i do need the money 200 pounds a lot
of money that's like his rent
so he starts working on it and it turns
out
that the suit is i guess it reanimates
the dead or
i also i think it reanimates inanimate
objects
well that's dumb isn't it it doesn't
reanimate inanimate options you know
what i mean it brings them to life okay
because it turns out that peter cushing
was making this
making the suit for his son and his son
was dead and he had
spent all of his money on this grimoire
that had this
recipe in it for a suit that you can
make and you put the suit on the dead
body and it brings the dead person back
to life
but then like later on when uh
you know a tussle occurs and peter
cushing ends up getting killed so that
whole thing doesn't happen
but then when bruno comes back home and
he's still got the suit
they put the suit or his wife puts the
suit on a mannequin
and then the mannequin comes to life and
like walks around so it's a pretty
powerful suit is what i'm saying so
that's like probably the weirdest
story like in all of them and like i
said you know peter cushing is in that
one so
now the third one is called lucy comes
to stay
more a psychological horror i think this
is uh this seems like it was the longest
uh segment and this actually stars both
charlotte rampling
and britt eklund so you know it's
basically
kind of like this reminded me a little
bit of uh you know trilogy
of terror like the one with what the
hell was that was that second i think it
was the second segment that was called
millicent and teresa or whatever it was
called
with karen black this is kind of a
little bit like that where
uh there's a woman named
barbara and she's played by charlotte
rambling she's the one that's in the
asylum at the moment
and she has been an asylum before but
she's telling about when this one time
where she got to leave
and she owns like this big beautiful
house and has all this money
but she's kind of like under the thumb
of her brother his name is george
and george is like not trusting her to
like not go to crazy town again
so he's basically like okay well you
have to take your meds and i'm gonna
hire a nurse like to take care of you
and
you have to be under guard all the time
so you don't like you know run around
like a loon
and uh so it turns out that at first you
think
although like i said you can pretty much
see where this one's going but uh at
first you think that she has this friend
named lucy who's played by brett eckland
who's kind of like a little bit of a
hellraiser and she's like man you can't
let them tell you what to do and we
gotta escape and all this other kind of
[ __ ] and they kind of end up going on a
murderous rampage or whatever but like i
said you find out at the end that
uh that lucy and barbara are actually
the same person they're like
you know split personality type thing so
like i said it's not like a big
shocker or anything and then the last
segment which is
kind of a segment but also ties in with
the wrap around maybe this one's the
weirdest one i mean the taylor one's
weird too but this one's
pretty weird so this one uh dr martin
the you know the dude that's
interviewing for the job now he's
interviewing
this other patient named dr byron and
dr byron has a hobby his hobby
is he makes these little people
they look kind of like ro okay so
they're like about
yay big right like however big that is
like a foot or so
maybe and um they're kind of like lego
robot bodies but then the head
is like realistic looking you know what
i mean like sculpted like clay or
whatever
and he's made them for all of the people
that he hates
in the asylum and elsewhere presumably
and
he has some kind of like weird [ __ ]
magic powers where if he concentrates
hard enough he says that
they're like robots or dolls or whatever
like on the outside but on the inside
they're like organic so
that's kind of like cronenbergian or
something like that i guess
but uh yeah so he's if he concentrates
hard enough they have like little bitty
brains in there and like little bitty
guts and whatnot
and he can like control their actions so
he's decided that he doesn't like dr
rutherford uh the dude that's
now running the asylum played by patrick
mcgee so he built this little thing
he built a little robot of himself to go
and stab dr rutherford with like with a
scalpel or whatever
which i i don't know that seems like a
real convoluted plan but um you know
whatever and
um and it works so who am i to judge you
know what i mean
but uh so yeah so that's kind of the
last part and even though it's not
really
as i said it's not really a
self-contained story because it ties in
with the whole framing device
because we're going back to the doctor
the head doctor the asylum and then this
guy and he wants to stab this other guy
and then at that point you um find out
through a series of uh circumstances
you find out who the mysterious doctor
star was
i will admit like i said i don't i don't
know i don't think i want to spoil it
because this is a movie that
if you really like you know the the
other amicus
um port banton movies you know the house
that dripped blood or
you know vault of horror or whatever um
you should really see this one because i
think this is actually one of the best
ones um it's just the pacing is real
good it's not a long film it's only like
83 minutes or something like that and it
moves along at a good clip like the
stories are pretty short
um you know some of them you can kind of
see where they're going but that's okay
and it's like it's not gory but it has
you know some cool like kind of creepy
imagery and some of the stories are just
like
so weird that there's like fascinating
to watch and like i said i really do
like
that they had that extra mystery element
of you trying to figure out like along
with dr martin who dr starr is like as
he interviews all of these people and
goes through all the stories
so like i said i guess i won't spoil it
but i will say
that i called it i called it because
i knew that there was going to be a
twist because you know we're so cynical
and jaded nowadays it's like
you can't even have a twist anymore
because everybody just expects it so
they know how
they're gonna be looking out for the
[ __ ] so i figured that there was gonna
be some big twist that it wasn't gonna
be
who you thought it was and i said well
who's like the least likely person or
who are they trying to make me seem as
though
make me think is the least likely person
and i'm like that's probably who it is
and i was right you know what i mean you
might be able to figure it out too but
we'll see yeah so apparently this
uh this movie was kind of like a little
bit
under the radar for a really long time
but i think
that uh severin just recently released
it on blu-ray with like you know all the
bells and whistles like all the uh
extras and stuff and i don't know if
it's by itself or it might be
or it might be with another amicus uh
anthology movie i'm you know i'm
my memory is blanking on that right now
but it does seem like there's like a
whole lot of extras on it
cinematography is fine it's you know
it's nothing like
spectacular but it's you know it does
the job acting is really good if you're
into british cinema at all you will
recognize pretty much everybody in this
movie
um you know not just peter cushing but
there's like tons of other really
well-known actors
who you know i guess in the case of like
charlotte rampling and stuff like that
this was kind of before she had done
the night porter i think so this was a
little bit before her kind of like big
breakout role but yeah so you'll pretty
much recognize everybody in here
and um as i said if you're into
anthology movies if you're if you like
british horror from this era at all like
hammer or anything like that then you sh
you should probably check this out
because um i actually really dug this
and uh at the moment if you're in the us
i'm not sure about uh
other countries it is on shutter shutter
actually just added a whole bunch of
um a whole bunch of amicus films
uh including and now the screaming
starts beast must die some other ones
like that
uh so yeah so if you're into that at all
then probably you should get shutter if
you don't have it already and go
watch it but yeah definitely check out
asylum from 1972
if you like anthologies at all and i
will
see you on the next flickers of fear bye